[音楽]
mhf
君は
10年目標を持っているか
これが私がマイクロそうとに入った時に聞かれたことでした
今日は
10年目標の力と題して10年目標が持つ力というものと
建て方その2つの話をしていきます
おそらく目標を持っている方もいるでしょうし持っていない方もいると思います
持っている方は今日私が話す目標と
自分の目標がどう違うか
そう思って聴いていただけると面白いと思います
持っていない方は私の話の後にちょっと考えてみようかなと思ってくれると私の話は
成功です
で話を始める前に少し戻って私の話をします
私は高校卒業後一浪して
とある国立大学に入りました
その後にバンドを始めたんですね
とても楽しくてその判明
大学のキャンパスライフがつまらなくなりました
私はちょっとやめようかなと考えたんですがせっかく大学入ったのに
でもこのままや卒業してですよ
バンドをする
もしくは今止めてバウンドを続ける
さんざん悩んだ結果私はやめることにしました
そのことは今でも私の両親に申し訳ないと思っています
その後東京に出てきた私は音楽でお金を稼ぐことは当然できずアルバイトをしたんです
ね
そこで運命的な出会いをします
私は windows というコンピュータに出会いました
忘れもしない2000年の暮れです
その時私は思ったんですこの windows という素晴らしいアプリケーションを
作った会社
マイクロ相当に入ろうと決めました
決めたんです
中退したへ
音楽しかやってない私が急にマイクロそうとに入る
周りの反応は
頑張ればいいじゃん
こんな感じですよねただすごく強く信じてくれる友達もいたのは嬉しかったです
windows さえわかれば私はマイクロ相当に入れると思って一生懸命勉強しまし
た
たくさん資格を取りました
しかし何も起きなかったです
諦めずに私は同僚にどうしればいいだろうと相談したところ
ネットワークを知っていたら強いよ
私はネットワークもたくさん勉強しました資格も取りました
しかし何も起きないです
まだまだ開けられませんまた同僚にどうすればいいだろうか
microsoft でしょ開発すべきでしょう
私は開発言語もたくさん勉強しました
資格もまたたくさん撮りました
それでも駄目でした
しかしまだまだ諦めません
microsoft は windows だけではなくてデータベースや他の製品も
たくさんあります
私はたくさん勉強してたくさん資格をとりまくりました
そして
2007年のクレイ党と私はマイクロそう手に入ることができましたん
ずっとダメだったのになぜか microsoft は当時
windows がわかってネットワークがわかって開発ができてデータベースも
わかる
さらに英語がしゃべれるそういう人材を探していたんですね
まさしく当時の私でした
私の努力は意味があったのです
ここまで聞くといい話なんですがやっと苦労して7年かかって31歳で入ったときに私
は初めの質問されたんです
君には10年目標があるか
ちょっと待ってて今散々頑張って弓を課題と入ったばっかり
ここで会っ
私は途方に暮れてものすごく次の目標を見つけるのに苦労しました
私は
[音楽]
君は目標を持っているかと言ってくれた方にどうすればいいか相談しました
すると彼は
目標というのは2つの作り方があるというのを教えてくれました
まず1つ目
これは積み上げ方式つまり今年なにしよう
来年どうしよう3年後は5年後は
今できることから考える方式ただこれは私にとっては常識だったんですが
その方が言うにはこれは良い方法ではない
私は microsoft に入りたいと急に思ったわけですよね
明らかにこの方法ではありません
では何があるかもう一つは夢から式
つまりやりたいことから考える夢という言葉が嫌いな方はやりたいことだと思って
ください
簡単じゃないか
しかし私はそれでもものすごく困りました
その話は少し後でします
でどうしていればやりたいことをもしか夢をですね
描けるのかもう一度相談者私に彼は
何もしがらみのない
何もなかった頃どんな夢を持っていたか思い出せばきっとうまくいくよと言ってくれた
ので私は子供の頃の夢を思い出すことにしました
小さい頃私はスポーツ選手になりたかったんです
プロ野球選手がですねいろいろあると思います
もしくは
クールなアーティスト
音楽をやった理由はこれですね
私の友達に至っては
ヒーローになりたい
そういうことを思うこともできたし
いうこともできました
ちなみに私はヒーローではないけれども一時期ですね
なんと消防車になりたいという夢を持っていました
かっこいいですよねー
これって人間がなれる夢かどうかちょっと分からないですね
そんなこんなをしながらいろいろ考えてたんですがその時に
私に教えてくれたのは
夢を考えるときやりたいことを考えるときには
ブロッカーというものがあるつまり邪魔をしてくるものがあるんです
夢を持つ時点で
達成するためではないですよ夢を持つ時点でブロッカーがあります
どんなものがあるかまず一つ目は現在の状況
私は microsoft にサポートエンジニアというお客様の問題を解決する職業
で入りました
その途端に私のやりたいことを夢はですね
サポートということに縛られてしまったんです
つまりより難しい問題を解決したい
製品の不具合を直す開発者になりたい
私はそのように言いました
それと彼は
それは
そのうちできることだろう
本当にやりたいことなのか
私は分からなくなってきました
何度も何度も私は彼にこれが僕のやりたいことだ
これが僕のやりたいことだといい続け彼は本当にそうなのか
その繰り返しによってのみ私はようやく
サポート今やっている仕事現在の状況というものから抜け出すことができました
もう一つのブロッカー
それは周囲の目です
私は小さいころたくさん勉強していたと自分では思っています
これは勉強が好きだったからではありません
両親や先生の期待があったからです
笑っていますよね皆さんポジティブに子供のことを見ています
子供は一生懸命それに応えていきますでもそれって本当に夢を追いかけていることなの
でしょうか
じゃあ私はそれをどうやって乗り越えたか
日本には空気を読むという言葉があります私がとった方法は簡単
今自分の考えは周囲の目によってできたものじゃないかということをまず気がつくこと
です
火がついたらどうするか無視するんです
無視した上でに自分の意見を頑張って載せていいます
つまり ky です
ただこれは空気を読めないではなくて空気を読まないです
そのスキルをひたすら磨いた私はもはや
ky のプロフェッショナルです
ただもう一つ最後にブロッカーがありました
それは
もったいない
得意ですよね我々
せっかく大学に入ったのに辞めるなんてもったいない
せっかく会社に行けたのに辞めるなんてもったいない
持っているものをして入れないつまり持っているものに縛られて
やりたいことが考えられないんです
これは練習しかないです
そしてようやく夢が見つかります
夢が見つかるとどうなるのでしょうか
今度はその夢のリスクを考え始めます
やったけど面白くなかったらどうしよう
やり方がわからないこれうまくいくのかな
これは一つコツがあります今やっていることを一生懸命やりながら横で少しずつでも
いいので
これが夢だと思ったことを捉えしてください
少しずつならリスクも少ないですやってみれば本当に面白いか分かります少しずつ
チャレンジをしてください
そしてこれが自分のやりたいことだこれが10年目標だと分かったとき
本題に戻って10年目標の力の話をします
目標の力もしくは夢の力は何でしょうか
それは叶うということですっていうとちょっとえ本当に
ありますよね
もう少し正確に言うと私の話を思い出してください
私は散々 microsoft に入りたいと希望してダメダメダメダメとなってき
ました
そのたびにどうしたか
何とか入りたいんですよ何をしてでもどんな手段を使ってでも
つまり
駄目でも駄目でも壁に当たっているのではなくて何とか抜け道を探して前に前に前に
進む
そのことが無限に続くそれが目標の力になります
目標さえ立てればいい
ただ私はその目標に向かって頑張りすぎた結果
地形を受けまくり
お金がなくなりました
試験第高いんです
私はどうしたか当時お付き合い教えた女性今の妻
にお金を借りて勉強しました
マイクロそうとに入った今そのお金は
まだ返していません
ただですよマイクロそうとに入れたので出張するときにですね海外に一緒に行けると
いうことできっと妻も満足しているのではないかなと思っています
今日その妻が会場に来てくれているので拍手をお願いします
[拍手]
で私の散々苦労したマイクのソートに入った後の目標はじゃあどうなったのかというと
私はスーパーエンジニアになるという女を立てました
これはマイクロそうとのことならどんなことでも応えれるという私の定義です
その結果入社当時17個持っていた
資格は現在105個になりました
そのおかげで私が書いたプログラムが
世界中で世界中のお客様に使われるというのは楽しい経験をしましたし
マイクロソフトの技術社員後6000人が世界から集まるカンファレンスでスピーチを
するというとても貴重な経験もさせていただきました
でもその夢10年たったから終わったんです
また次の10年考えないといけない
今回私は2つの夢を同時に考えることができました
一つは仕事に関することでまぁ今仕事の話はしたのでこれは今回は離さないですもう一
つはプライベートの夢を見つけました
私のプライベートの夢はストリートワークアウトという競技で
全日本大会に出ることです
ストリートハカートって何そうですよね
ストリートワーカーとというのはこの写真のように自分の体一つでパフォーマンスを
するそういう種目です
今日着ているこの服も私のスポーツあのストリートワーカーとのチームのシャツになり
ます
どうでしょうか
皆さんが持っている目標というものと私が今日話をした目標というものは同じだった
でしょうか
違ったでしょうか
もしくは
あまり目は考えたくない目標も持ちたくないと思っている方もいると思いますが今日私
の話を聞いてちょっと神経に考えてみようと思っていただければ嬉しいです
つまり自分の夢っていうものを真剣に考えるそういう機会というのはすばらしいもので
夢は持ちたいすれば
ひたすら前に進めるそういった力を持っています
なので私が今日言った3つのブロッカー
現在の状況周囲の目そして
8もう一つ自分で言ってて忘れましたね
もったいないですねこの3つ
考えて十分の夢を持ってください
私の話もだいぶ最後になりましたが私は今後
何年生きられるか分かりませんけれども残りの人生であと何個この10年目標がモテる
のか
そう考えるだけで非常にワクワクしています
ありがとうございました
[拍手]